Materials discovery can now imagine millions of crystals.
Google DeepMind’s GNoME proposed 2.2 million.
But by late 2023, only 736 had been
independently synthesized. The scarce resource is no longer
prediction. It is trust.
Every stage leaks. Generators omit complex material classes.
Universal machine-learned potentials are least reliable at surfaces,
vacancies, and defects. And laboratories inherit every upstream
error. More activity does not automatically produce more
validated materials.
Lupine Science sits between prediction and synthesis.
It measures a predictor’s systematic error as a
physical field over local atomic environments, corrects that
error at runtime, and proves which claims remain
inside the evidence boundary.
The field is fixed by three standard observables.
A fourth surface is held back as a
blind test. Across 36 model-and-material combinations, predicted and
measured errors correlate at zero point nine oh
six—with zero adjustable parameters.
Quantitative claims are then sealed as Lean 4
theorems with hash-locked provenance.
The proof layer has 190 build-locked theorems and
zero unfinished proofs. It once rejected a rounded
success count, changing 27 improvements to 26.
Trust means being able to say no to
yourself.
The correction deploys beside existing CHGNet or MACE
calculators as a LAMMPS overlay.
In Python, measured overhead is 15.6 percent.
On a blind nickel surface, relative error fell
from 9.7 percent to 1.5 percent.
Users keep their simulators.
Lupine makes them more trustworthy.
Better materials infrastructure is estimated to create 123
to 270 billion dollars in annual value for
United States industry. Against that scale, Lupine’s 36-month
budget is about 3.2 million dollars.
The investment is not a bet on one
material. It is leverage across every screened material.
The face-centered-cubic field is established.
Other structure families and industrial validation remain open
work, with explicit go-or-no-go gates.
That honesty is the product.
The world does not need more predicted crystals.
It needs predictions laboratories can act on.